hi everybody my name is Johnny Reinhardt
formerly known as an eater procedure and
today I'm gonna be giving the kind
people here at BuzzFeed one-minute
makeovers one-minute makeovers get your
one-minute makeovers oh hi Dan nice to
meet you step on into my little boudoir
here so I get a little bit of a rock and
roll vibe from you you also smell very
nice those are a little bit I'm
conflicting things like think about like
Ozzy Osbourne at the end of the night on
a bar crawl okay here we go so I'm gonna
start with black it's a very good place
to start wow this is incredible I see
the real you coming through you have
anyone special in your life Dan any
romantic partner I'm married
Wow well that might all end today all
this makeover no I'm just kidding you're
gonna look great we've got one eye down
now we're gonna go for the other eye
that's how things go when you do one eye
you want to make sure you also do you
heard it here first people we're gonna
go give you that underride that Ozzy
Osbourne if they had to see you so it's
not just the makeup the hair can I just
your hair a little bit in there yeah
let's go to that gives me the Rockstar
like I don't care look you look like a
British rocker like you're from the 1975
I'm gonna add a little red just for
drama oh there's still some purple on it
from a previous three - Wow
yay the look will be finished once
you've cried and you had like 16 beers
and I'm excited for you to go out into
the world as the rocker that you were
always meant to be
thanks Dan nice to meet you nice to meet
you a nice and you oh my gosh
you are very gorgeous you're very
beautiful so what brings you and what
are you hoping to get here today at the
one-minute well there's nothing on my
face currently okay I just don't really
need your help really you don't need any
makeup and I'm just gonna show you how
much fun makeup can be so I'm gonna dip
into this palette here called the real
me I'm gonna put on some of this like
primer it's kind of goopy so you just
want to blend it out blending is a
secret is there anyone special in your
life
would you like there to be no I'm
actually taking a break you know what
yes pause the time so I can say a
Clinton yes high five mm time back okay
cool I just wanted to make sure that you
knew that I was living for that okay so
I'm doing kind of a neutral base here
and what kind of people are you
interested in and I normally end up with
some sort of douchebag but not you
well this trying to find the nice guys
this makeup is not gonna be for
douchebags this makeup is gonna be for
men that have jobs no that's I not have
good relationships with them I'll be
able to compare 401k absolutely okay so
I'm using like a dark kind of chocolatey
and eye shadow I don't even know what
I'm using at this point okay lip color
on you here with this whole new makeup
look you're gonna go out you're gonna
catch a guy who is not a douchebag and
who has like a reasonable amount of
Instagram followers okay here's trayless
gorgeous fresh and dewy
all right Caitlyn thank you so much
high-five baby you so much I want you to
have everything good in this life okay
no God and get it oh so proud well my
name is Johnny I'm Arianna Aria nice to
meet you Oh like the hotel in Vegas well
you know what don't say anything else
that inspires me and the inspiration is
gonna be Vegas [ __ ] oh yeah all right so
I'm gonna start with like [ __ ] black
have you spent much time in Vegas I
actually got married in Vegas did you oh
you're married oh that might make the
[ __ ] thing a little bit tricky but
hopefully your partner is willing to be
open well no longer marry so I'm more
than happy to be a [ __ ] the twists and
the turns
have you been back recently no I haven't
I was there last year for a fourth
invention them oh my god I've been to a
porn convention in Vegas I think we have
a lot more in common than I would have
initially thought are you so what really
puts [ __ ] makeup to the next level is
the color blue it really says like
streetwalker it's like very pretty woman
except like not very pretty now we're
gonna go in with [ __ ] red so just open
your mouth for now and this is a long
wear lipstick so this should stay on the
Bellagio fountains gonna spray this off
honey more is more with a look like this
is there any advice that I could give
you well I'm actually about to start
training for a fight any advice for
looking good in the Rings try a nice
tinted moisturizer before you go in and
maybe you're gonna false lash and
actually that might give you the upper
hand in the fight this is gonna be a
look that really stops traffic I think
we really nailed this Las Vegas hooker
look and I think that you're gonna have
a lot of clients just like you know in a
[ __ ] way you know just very open like
kind of like a hey hey hey you know it's
like a swagger down the street the next
porn convention you and me were there
honey we're gonna work it out
thanks aria bye thank you peace and
blessings get tested every three months
looks like hung top is 127 feet away
hey you're not hung top my name is
Gianni Adriana Adriana nice to meet you
give me three words to describe you
crazy optimistic and funny okay well I'm
gonna create a look that says all of
those things I want you to choose from
these titles city glitz first date happy
hour for dinner at 8:00 I like dinner at
8:00 all right dinner at 8:00 it is I'll
make the reservation so I'm gonna start
with this really nice like deep lip is
there anyone I'm special and interesting
in your life right now no I kind of went
through my whole phase a couple months
ago it was like a sprint and you know
you're tired after spring bother you
know like
oh honey you don't need to tell me that
hoeing is exhausting regarding your home
phase how was that was that liberating
for you
yeah I think I learned a lot about what
I wanted a person I learned you can be
like I want to be little boy and then he
doesn't mean do you absolutely in this
life you just have to ask for what you
want and then go out and get it honey oh
you are looking good honey
so how's your career been going darling
I think it's in on the up and up but
it's not toad lately well sometimes all
you need to spice things up in the
workplace is a new look this is what's
gonna get any hired full-time absolutely
I'm gonna give you a little blush I'm
gonna show you this hair a little you
got really cute little bangs three two
one two camera gorgeous that is a
beautiful femme fatale from the 1940s
isn't it she's ready to sleep with a man
and then murder him get out there and
commit murder
whoo well that's all the time we have
today for one-minute makeovers I hope
that we've encouraged you today to play
with some makeup to get out there and be
your most authentic self and possibly
commit some crimes until next time I'm
Johnny Reinhard's
[Music]